c'est matthieu delormeau qui s'est fait
piéger par où jean michel maire ah ah
mais regardez matthieu delormeau il a
toujours un coup d'avancé
on lui a proposé une fausse paparazzade
regardez ça c'est parti comment ça va
toujours jaloux génère chantait
zemmouchi tout bon bah écoute sympa way
intervient sous ce nom mais pourrait
coûter à ba oui je suis content alors
oui bien sûr on était mieux carrément à
pied le chemin des filets bientôt 11 ans
ça va profiter à pied c'était cadeau de
syrie ils n'auront pas vu comment je
fais j'ai emménagé dans sa loge et je me
sers tu aimes bien ça dit oui je
pourrais tout le préfet mais je te
présente julien quelques photographes
qui m'a contacté en fin de semaine
dernière
moi je vais me proposait alors une sorte
de fausse paparazzade un truc qui
pourrait nous faire du cash pour tout le
monde quoi en gros pendant qu'ici on
fait un truc genre dans la rue avec un
snack tu vas pris un peu à la volée à la
rage soit sorti de soirée soit en plein
jour on s'en fiche un médecin qui boit 2
ou battu les doubles je suis pas tant la
gent jeune agent je crois que tu avais
mis en avant de parler le quai si c'est
pas du tout coupé ibm et crédible ap ou
pas d'ailleurs ce sera pas prêt pour le
coup on peut faire un truc qui nous
augmentera le tarier des gens peut-être
je suis pas animé le bal jean saisrien
faudrait jouer avec moi d'actifs mais en
gros ce serait génial la photo ou deux
fois de sauver sa vie chacun pour un
truc un peu j'en tue ses ambiances hôtel
un peu à poil tu sais sortie de trucs un
peu un peu un peu discretos a parfois la
toile c'est beaucoup plus que 10 minutes
selon pti non roger muraro dit la vérité
c'est qu'on me proposait n'y a pas très
longtemps et que vous avez accepté
maman des années et karine ferri de
faire un truc comme ça car il s'est
passé c'est que là il faut un break poli
mais avec son mec là et leur proposer de
faire un peu comme ça bon franchement
j'ai dit oui ça fait marrer et les
installer plutôt joli le posséder plus
de 10000 enfin prêt pour un gros en
temps je peux avoir un très constant mal
plus sextape genre de truc à 58 que tu
pousses un peu on va être très très
clément 6 cd [ __ ] que c'est pour
l'argent donc on va être très clair moi
si tu me proposes plus qu'elle je trouve
un bateau de la nuit même si c'est moins
honnêtement pour moi c'est pas j'adore
jean-louis mais j'essaie conclure il en
rire avec karine qu'avec jean mi quand
tu vois elle postule à la vérité elle
elle m'assure et 2000
donc tu as eu propose 14 de 15g pas
l'annuler pour 2000 euros + maintenant
si effectivement on était plus proche
des 18 20 je serai moins du coup je
perds dans un an il vous assure je te
fais un petit montage à la pompe pour
donner une idée de ce que ça pourrait
être en plomb alors je vais faire un
petit truc
voilà ce sera un truc un peu tombant
alors j'ai pris congé cgfr montage et
choqué corps sur internet si c'est
encore le cas de mélanomes et ça la met
en avant sont pas sur un truc c'est un
contre-exemple personnes et 50 total de
lindsey
on discute un petit peu on parle plus
charge en apparemment lattier et
jean-michel je serais assez chaud pour
remplir le pas pour sextape par segment
d'activité dit lui la faute aux saintes
manama et tout ça par personne 25
octobre
il était très drôle c'est mon présent
est au cousin un bar et qui rassure le
pognon passe très mal pris mais beaucoup
moins pour 25 min pour notre part d'y
entrer mais c'est le nombre de
téléspectateurs sur l'émission
avec karine silla c'est être en paix non
plus facilement maire de ciboure en être
entretenue on est plus connu qu donc
qu'il est 65 dit qu'il est bah oui et
puis moi je suis je suis plus grosse
gamelle sinon j'espère 985 me mais la
photo ça avance à 25 pour moi 25% et
pour aujourd'hui et pour jouer leur race
leur est écolo reste cherche pas une
plombèrent tu dis quoi
bayeux prendra le reste ce chrono reste
25 chacun est d'accord là ok après moi
ça ne choquait pas et j'en oublie ça ne
choquera pas c'est mon ami ça me choque
pas que moi je suis pas y ait un peu
plus c'est comme adriana karembeu est
vos pulsions photo christine tu vois ce
que j'entends et je peux entendre si on
doit jeter crise voilà tandis que du
coup ça après on s'en fout on statut moi
je reviens pas je me dis moi je suis ça
marche toujours cette histoire de photo
[Musique]
parce que - histoire c'est que de mentir
aux tweets fait tu vas faire croire des
choses pour quelques uns à ne pas
manquer je pense que le romantisme il
faut retourner pour moi je sais pas si
c'est très dur et donc les a vite mis
dans sa poche ses convictions am the
wind et pourtant dans des tapis près de
monter les prix depuis
non je vais savoir s'il 3 du coup tu
peux
trente minutes 30 mais non mais tu te ça
émouvant n'est pas mon avis - revenant
là parce que tartuffe printemps
haussmann en écoule ses coûts ce qui
t'arrive basse et bien oui non si c'est
bienvenu on sait oui je vais pas de voir
des trucs mais il hésite entre entre
deux plans qui l'a tenu pendant trente
monde et ce serait qu'on aime pour 39 ce
serait bon ou pas trente minutes pas
justin maison dans 5 minutes voilà
rapide se dire qu'après la trentenaire
un bisou ouais je sais comment je te
rappelle mais je te dis moi je pense que
c'est c'est eh bien ni pourtant des
pendus moi je veux bien sûr en carrière
ok je te fais destot fait des bisous je
te rappelle sauf moi c'est évoquer aussi
visée parce que c'est le mieux pour elle
va le faire voici une copine je préfère
dire que pour moi c'est mieux non mais
là où c'est pareil
tremblay chacun trois points chacun non
ça je crois que tu prends tu vois pas où
ça va tu pousses un singe magot 20 des
normes ans et 10 mois je vois la moitié
de toi en groupe ou je te refile mi16
j'apprécie vraiment d'être le conte du
coup à quoi tu es des si et quand même
pas quoi mais non melhout était à la
pression qui situe le fait qu'elle
fonctionne sur la persécution et une
somme trop louche et une sur ton dos bah
tu sais toute l'admiration que j'ai pour
toi c'était le coeur joie à son pied moi
c'est moi
toutes les missions à toi t'as pas été
c'est un jeune chaîne au royaume la
lumière tu te mets sur jean mis sur mes
genoux dans votre nature maison syrie
dit que je ne ferais jamais de nature et
le monde il faut un truc qui sont un peu
crédible
qu est ce que tu crois qu'il ya un truc
plutôt la faute aux gens on sort de
boîte et jean à laitière un peu avec les
vapeurs d'alcool tout comme ça tu fais
un espagnol moins que l'on puisse penser
qu'on boit de l'alcool
le champomy pour toi mais cette photo m
ca pas un truc calculé jean et son
humiliation pour la maintenance qu'on
peut faire et qui peut être pas tqc on
est en train on est tous de l'impôt sont
en train de prendre un verre à toi tu as
ta tête sur mon épaule et trois sur fond
c'est que tu ne prenait pas traiter nos
citoyens a tout fait pour que ça si vous
faites ça sur la table un mot ni toi ni
rien karine ferri à part maintenant un
personnage ouais mais c'est moi j'ai pas
mal mais j'ai pas ma tête sur les
épaules la limite c'est toi qui viens où
est ta tête sur les épaules que chez moi
je suis dit non non mais après ça ce
serait dangereuse mignon mettez-vous au
mieux la terrasse là on monte un tout
petit peu a encore un tout petit peu
stop me canonica
oui bah tiens on va pas en plus sur le
titanic
justement c'est là c'est déjà space qui
mon ami qu'elle bouge pas moi je
m'ennuie c'est tout on est en tête sur
son épaule nickel bouge pas c'est
ridicule la branche s'immiscer dans le
quotidien d'un coup un nom ouais
embrassez vous la vidéo au revoir c'est
vous c'est parti bah ouais il prend 30
minutes a eu deux premiers du soutien à
l'émeute
ouais un petit but sur un jour mais tu
es touche les cheveux
1 2 3 ouais super super les gars ont
bien ou pas bravo quand même c'est pas
crédible une seule seconde je vous
montre les photos du tout à fait ce que
je racontais mois elles sont jolies
ah oui ça peut faire chaud togolais
c'est joli ça nous a assez bien en
revanche photo titanic non non mais
titanic elle est un peu flou non mais
what you want semaine dans merial est
rompu
c'est mathieu de végéter
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
c'était mignon qu'il est plus les jambes
parce que c'était quand même c'est ça
l'histoire et à l'optimisation huawei
accepté lui pour le tbhc caméra cachée
parce que oui vous avez pas compris qu
il savait que c'est une caméra fait
d'émules vous n'avez pas que vous aidera
la combine je croyais je savais que
c'était une caméra cachée au niveau de
la conférence